[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
les jeux olympiques de tokyo 2020
reportée pour cause de pandémie auront
finalement lieu à partir du 23 juillet
on va passer cette dernière émission de
la saison avec richard var gignac qui
publie histoire des jeux olympiques un
livre qui couvre tous les jeux de
l'époque moderne d'athènes en 1896 à
paris en demie aux mille 2024 mais
d'abord une image symbolisant notre
époque voici celle que vous avez choisi
c'est qui c'est qui massa un enfant
c'est un père avec son enfant j'ai
choisi cette photo pour ma pour
plusieurs raisons la paternité déjà je
pense que comme tout papa à partir du
moment où on tient pour pour la première
fois son enfant dans les bras on est
marqué à jamais et c'est une aventure
qui commence
une belle aventure une aventure de
transmission une aventure où on
accompagne son enfant bas pendant toute
la vie c'est aussi en hommage à ce
prolongement du congé paternité qui
arriva ya pas très longtemps
et moi j'ai deux garçons donc mon aîné
va sur ses 20 ans et j'ai été un des
premiers papa de france à bénéficier du
congé paternité de 3 à 11 jours mais
vous en 2000 a donc pris vous en 2002 et
je l' ai vraiment pris voilà à mon seul
problème du congé paternité c'est que
les pères le prennent pas exactement
exactement et je pense que la société
évolue mais la société étant ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
des papas doivent et fonds et prennent
leur place de père aujourd'hui
et voilà moi c'est un honneur de mes
deux fils pour mes deux fils hugo et
raphaël d'être au quotidien avec eux de
les accompagner
on a beau être présentateur écrivain
chauffeur de camion on est père et ça
c'est la plus belle aventure pour moi et
bien commençons
[Musique]
histoire des jeux olympiques est paru
chez mareuil édition les jeux de tokyo
commenceront donc le 23 juillet dans des
conditions très particulières
ils seront probablement uniques en leur
genre ces jeux quoi qu'il arrive ils
seront uniques puisque déjà avant tout
ce seront les premiers jo sans public
ouais ou en tout cas sans public
étranger avec ce côté extrêmement
aseptisé du fait de la pandémie mondiale
ce seront des jeux où la vie du village
olympique ne sera pas pareil
ce seront des jeux où les athlètes ne
seront pas accompagnés par leur famille
avec un minimum de volée priera de
reprendre l'avion aussitôt qu'ils auront
été éliminées au règlement ne dira pas
de rester pour profiter du village
exactement et puis la vie du village
olympique dans l'histoire c'est quelque
chose on en reparlera peut-être tout à
l'heure et voilà et ce sont aussi des
officiels où on a demandé à tous les
officiels ou chefs detat de venir avec
un contingent extrêmement réduit donc
voilà mais il y aura quoi qu'il arrive
du sport et je crois que c'est
l'essentiel pour le cio pour les
japonais c'est que l'événement se
tiennent malgré tout oui parce que ça
leur a coûté quand même bon de reculer
d'un an vous le racontez dans votre
livre ça laisse un film il ya exactement
et ç'aurait pu encore leur coûter
beaucoup plus s'il l'avait annulée
escalettes est terrible aussi c'est pour
les athlètes parce que le report des
jeux étaient à drame pour un certain
nombre d'athlètes exactement on peut
prendre l'exemple de notre porte drapeau
clarisse agbegnenou qui est quintuple
championne du monde de judo et clarisse
agbegnenou avait avait programmé sa
carrière pour enfin décrocher le graal
olympique en 2020 puisqu'elle avait fini
à la deuxième place à rio en 2016
effectivement pour elle ça a été un
frein totale puisque elle était prête
pour 2020 mais du coup il fallait
anticiper et derrière se projeter sur
2021 et là ça n'a pas été simple mais
bon à la rente a remporté son cinquième
titre
il ya quelques jours et on peut que lui
souhaiter d'être décroché son graal
olympique alors remontons au départ de
votre livre aux premiers jeux olympiques
modernes at
non en 1896 à l'époque il ya il n'y a
que 14 pays et vous raconter longuement
et j'ai retrouvé des photos les épreuves
de natation à l'époque c'était pas dans
une piscine comme aujourd'hui c'était
pas dans une piscine chauffée loup et ed
c'était dans la cité dans la mer dans la
baie du pirée l'eau était à 12 degrés on
le voit là ils sont sûrs d accompagner
avec des bateaux enfin c'est ça lève
c'est vraiment le sait c'est le far west
c'est le far west c'est fait avec les
moyens de l'époque l'essentiel déjà à
l'origine c'est de savoir aussi que les
premiers jeux n'était pas prévue à
athènes
pierre de coubertin si vous qu'il ya là
à l'initiative de la renaissance
olympique voulait les faire à paris on
les ignore
c'était à la sorbonne que ça a été
décidé tout ça s'est décidé à tête en
1894 pour les yeux de paris sa fera 130
ans exactement
et en fait la sorbonne il avait il avait
invité tous les patrons des fédérations
internationales de sport il avait invité
aussi des barons des barons des des
personnages des princes des personnages
influents pour justement à soirée avoir
une assise solide pour affirmer ce
mouvement olympique et il voulait faire
coïncider les premiers gio avec
l'exposition universelle de 1900 à paris
sauf que
la pression du roi grec
il voulait absolument les jeux à la tène
et coubertin grand prince lui a accordé
et donc effectivement on a on a dès les
premiers jeux olympiques avec quatorze
nations des jeux qui ont été un succès
des jeux qui ont été un succès puisque
un succès populaire
un succès grâce à spiridon louis conte
savoir qui est le vainqueur du marathon
épreuve reine pendant très longtemps
l'épreuve reine des jeux c'était le
marathon c'est plus tellement le cas
aujourd'hui c'est de 900 mètres
d'aujourd'hui oui parce qu'aujourd'hui
il faut du spectaculaire qui passe à la
télé marathon c'est pas à toi tu vois le
premier vainqueur du marathon et c'est
devenu un héros national et peut-être la
première star du sport au fond la
première star du sport la première star
olympique spiridon louis venait d'un
milieu assez assez pauvre il
accompagnait son papa qui livrait de
l'eau tous les jours à athènes il
courait à côté du chariot et il a été
repéré au cours de son service militaire
par un certain papa diamantopoulos on
peut on pourra peut être en parler un
petit peu après et en fait ils avaient
de réelles qualités et donc il s'est
présenté mais à l'époque courir 40
kilomètres donc reproduire cette fameuse
histoire de marathon après la bataille
de marathon la victoire des grecs sur
les perses et philippidès qui va donner
la nouvelle au roi grec à athènes et
et qui meurent selon la légende de pied
du roi en lui annonçant la victoire
grecque et donc ils veulent reproduire
cette course et du coup la première
course par deux marathons jusqu'à
athènes 40 km et spiridon louis
en fait on n'avait pas trop les
informations comme aujourd'hui c'était
en direct à la télé et du coup la rumeur
disait que la victoire allait revenir à
un étranger et papa aux grecs
il y avait des milliers de personnes sur
les routes est en fait on vient annoncer
la nouvelle au stade panathénaïque
d'athènes
dix ans c'est un étranger qui va gagner
le marathon et alors là tout le monde
est abattu
tout le monde est abattu sauf que un
coup de canon retentit et papa de gens
demandent tokyo los arrive à vélo et
donne la nouvelle spiridon louis arriver
là c'est c'est l'extase c'est l'extase
les jeux auront bien lieu à paris en
1900 comme le souhaitait coubertin mais
alors là vous vous dévoiler quelque
chose qu'on a un peu oublié aujourd'hui
c'est que ces couplé avec l'exposition
universelle est en fait c'est pas des
vrais jeux olympiques c'est ce sont des
des concours qui ont lieu en marge de
l'exposition universelle qui elle se
tient pendant cinq mois
à l'époque c'était très bon une
exposition universelle est en fait les
jeux olympiques c'est talent pendant
cinq mois à l'intérieur c'est pas du
tout la même ambiance en fait c'est à
peine si les gens savent qu'ils sont aux
jeux olympiques en réalité c'est ça pour
faire la genèse de ces jeux en fait vous
avez l'organisateur de cette exposition
universelle s'appelait alfred picard et
qui souhaitait en fait faire la
promotion du sport de masse un petit peu
c'était c'était vraiment son approche
est en phase coubertin qui qui
promouvait là le sport un peu élitiste
la performance individuelle et donc du
coup il ya eu un conflit entre les deux
où l'on voulait prendre le dessus sur
l'autre le cio d'un côté l'exposition
universelle de l'autre et au final
coubertin à s'est résolu à dire
effectivement on accordera ce ces
événements sportifs comme comme deuxième
olympiade
et effectivement du coup ça a été
réparti sur plusieurs mois
donc avec
des sports ne reviendra pas mais voilà
deux toutous style est effectivement
vous avez notamment une américaine qui
s'appelait abrite ce qu'est ce que c'est
très important c'est la première fois
qu'il ya des femmes c'est la première
coupe bertone voulait pas de femmes
et comme il a un peu perdu cette année
là il y aura des femmes pour la première
fois et j'ai appris d'ailleurs en lisant
votre livre qu'on arrivera à la parité
homme-femme que à paris en 2024
exactement et c'est là il ya évidemment
eu avec son quad 12 ou 13 - wendy et ça
montera mais elles vont être 20 30% des
des sportifs présents aux jeux
olympiques et c'est seulement en 2024
qui aura la parité tout à fait tout à
fait sur dix mille cinq cents athlètes
en 2024
la moitié sera de sexe féminin
et pour revenir juste à 1900 vous aviez
une américaine qui s'appelait abbott et
qui est là avec sa mère pour profiter de
l'exposition universelle d'étrelles
d'ailleurs non c'était du elle faisait
du golfe à passer du golfe et abbott
participe à un concours de golf
international et le remporte et sa mère
finit 6e et c'est quelques semaines
après où elle reçoit une lettre disant
qu'elle avait gagné les jeux olympiques
elle ne le savait pas c'était pareil je
me suis trompé mais elle s'est bien
marguerite abbott et donc la place de la
femme dans le sport enfin voila c'est
tout un sujet qui pourrait largement
faire aussi office d'un ouvrage sur
l'olympisme et la femme puisque c'est un
cheminement de reconnaissance qui
aboutit seulement qui va aboutir
seulement en 2024
alors ça louis de 1904 vous dites que
sont les jeux de la honte
d'abord les européens ne veulent pas
venir parce que c'est trop loin puis ils
ont sans doute d'oraison et puis surtout
il ya le plus gros scandale dites vous
de l'histoire des jeux et on envoie des
photographies là derrière vous c'est que
on va organiser des compétitions dit
anthropologique pour les peuples de
couleur
c'est typiquement américain quoi c'est à
dire qu'on va voilà c'est l'idée et en
plus on veut véritablement faire passer
l'idée qu'ils ne sont pas au niveau
oui en fait déjà l'exposition
universelle de 1900 4 à saint louis il
reprend un petit peu des canons de celle
de 1900 à paris où il y avait des os
humains des il avait il y avait des des
personnes exposées et où on venait
visiter le lundi gènes provenant d'une
lointaine contrée est en fait les
américains en 1904 voulait aussi montrer
par des espèces d' analyse
anthropologique montré que la race
blanche était supérieur à aux autres et
donc du coup ils ont invité pendant deux
jours lors de jours de jeu
anthropologique
ils ont invité des des pygmées des
indiens des syriens tout ce qu'ils
estimaient comme différents et ils leurs
données et leurs données sur la première
journée à accomplir des épreuves
olympiques donc sans préparation sans
explication on les a lâchés dans la
nature comme ça donc effectivement quand
on compare ensuite les résultats il n'y
a pas photo et la 2e journée
là on les a laissés pratiquer leur sport
traditionnel entre guidon l'arc l'arc ou
la montée d'une d'une poutre d'une
dizaine de mètres où là effectivement
voilà les conclusions les conclusions
entre guillemets je le répète d'experts
de l'époque
et bah oui ils sont bons dans leur
domaine mais dans les nôtres
ce qui prouve que la race blanche et
indéniablement supérieur aux autres
c'est aussi les jeux olympiques
dites-vous de la triche et du dopage
tout à fait tout à fait et on revient au
marathon justement on peut on peut
encore citer le marathon de 1904 où il
ya une anecdote incroyable incroyable
sur le marathon où la course
on est encore dans les études
anthropologiques du coup sur les 40 km
les organisateurs décident de d'étudier
d'observer un petit peu
les conséquences d'un tel effort sur le
corps humain donc pendant 20 km les 20
premiers kilomètres on va leur donner
deux fois de l'eau et sur les 20
derniers kilomètres plus rien et donc
dans ces conditions là vous vous avez un
américain qui a abou qui monte dans une
voiture et qui fait plus près de la
moitié de la course en voiture qui
redescend et qu'il ya qui passe la ligne
d'arrivée en premier donc là une triche
une triche comme on en a jamais vu comme
on n'en avait jamais vu sauf que
l'entraîneur du du deuxième celle qui
arrive est second derrière lui a bien vu
la supercherie est en fait voilà juste
avant de de serre passer la médaille
d'or voilà tout est remis et le dopage
ce ce deuxième qui est finalement arrivé
premier avait pris quelques petits
produits aussi non homologués enfin
voilà le dopage c'est un petit peu comme
l'histoire de la place de la femme
ça a été un long cheminement avant
justement de faire rentrer ça dans les
moeurs comme ça l'est aujourd'hui
mais je pense qu'on ne reviendra aussi
justement mais aujourd'hui on peut faire
des on peut aller dans l'avenir
aujourd'hui on
on sait que les contrôles anti dopage on
est extrêmement vigilant très avertis
deçà mais on est presque intégrer l'idée
qui aura toujours des affaires de dopage
et on a vu tellement de grands champions
dénoncer ensuite pour s'être dopé et et
perdre leur titre et leurs médailles
qu'on est un peu blasés faut pas être
blasé parce qu'en fait la vie d'un
athlète de haut niveau est d'autant plus
de ce niveau là est extrêmement encadrée
en athlète doit doit rendre compte au
quotidien en anticipant sur son
calendrier pour justement pouvoir être
présents en cas de contrôles antidopage
inopinés
et ça dans la vie de tous les jours ce
n'est pas forcément évident des fois on
a envie de faire un break et où il faut
quand même dire où on va se trouver à
telle heure à tel endroit
et donc oui effectivement le dopage
aussi a toujours un temps d'avancé sur
l'antidopage
et c'est ça aussi qui fait l'histoire
des du sport en général au delà des jeux
olympiques on peut parler du football
des contres grandes courses cyclistes et
autres
c'est vrai que le doigt est toujours
pointé sur le cyclisme est bon les jeux
olympiques ont prouvé aussi qu' il y
avait de quoi faire
il y avait de quoi faire alors il ya un
londres les jeux olympiques de londres
en 1908 vous dites c'est un peu les
premiers vrais jeux olympiques c'est un
peu les premiers vrais jeux olympiques
puisque pour la première fois ils sont
pas rattachés hormis 1896 ils sont pas
directement rattaché à l'exposition
universelle
et là effectivement on laisse place on
les divise quand même par temporalité
les les jeux de printemps les jeux d'été
les jeux d'hiver
il faut savoir aussi qu'à l'époque il y
avait pas de jeux olympiques d'hiver
donc par exemple en en 1900 par exemple
coubertin voulait faire du patinage
artistique à paris mais bon
techniquement c'était pas possible donc
là effectivement c'était place aux
sportifs à l'athlète
mais il devait pas avoir lieu à londres
il devait avoir lieu à rome ont mis en
1908 et en fait vous avez un séisme en
1906 qui intervient ceis power6
m'excuser à mouguerre d'une éruption du
vésuve est pompée y compris et nakhlé
naples et
est extrêmement touché les dégâts
incommensurables et du cou du coup
l'état italien décide d'annuler les
gigots face aux coûts déjà de la
catastrophe
cumuleo coup c'était pas possible pour
donc londres se présente
et voilà il fait le maximum pour faire
des jeux les plus sportifs possible vous
raconter cette anecdote elle me paraît
dingue que la famille royale voulant
assister au départ du marathon de la
pelouse de son château de windsor
le marathon des jeux olympiques de
londres en 1908 et plus longue habitude
exactement exactement c'est en fait les
petits enfants de la famille royale qui
ayant entendu les histoires précédentes
sur spiridon louis sur le fameux
marathon de 1904 avec cette fameuse
triche voulait absolument absolument
voir partir le le départ depuis leur
jardin sauf qu'entre le jardin de
windsor et la ligne d'arrivée du stade
olympique
ce n'était pas 40 km c'était 42,195 km
enfin 42 km 195 m et du coup eh ben
c'est la distance officielle aujourd'hui
sauf que cette distance là était
officiellement reconnue par la
fédération internationale d'athlétisme
en 1921 ans je crois et donc voilà donc
ils ont eu leur départ sur la pelouse et
l'arrivée au stade et c'est aussi la
première année on fait le bilan par pays
où on compte les médailles pour chaque
pays bilan qui moi m'a toujours paru
absurde à quoi ça rime de comparer les
résultats de l'amérique qui est un pays
de plusieurs centaines de millions
d'habitants et ceux de la suisse par
exemple c'est absurde c'est absurde
faudrait faire au prorata de la
population et même corrigé par le pib
c'est aussi qu'en fonction du pib
il est quand même plus facile de gagner
des médailles contre l'état pays riches
bien sûr la soirée du sens mais tel qu
on le fait ça n'en a aucun bien sûr en
fait
ce n'était pas du tout une volonté du
cio qui n'a jamais reconnu ce classement
par pays choses soient très claires pour
les jo
ce sont des épreuves individuelles et on
n'est pas dans le nationalisme
on n'est pas dans dans la comparaison
entre états mais en moins c'est le cio
qui a voulu le podium les drapeaux les
hymne à la on est dans le folk lo
olympique effectivement coubertin est un
passionné de graisse de grèce antique et
il a il a repris certains canons donc
effectivement on est passé tout de suite
à 1908 à londres mais vous avez des jeux
intermédiaires les jeux de 1906 à
athènes pour le dixième anniversaire est
en fait ces jeux ont été extrêmement
important dans cette histoire du folk lo
justement olympiques puisque c'est là où
est à paris le défilé des nations où on
défile derrière le drapeau de son pays
avec un porte drapeau avec le nom du
pays s'est pas encore là où la grèce
défilent en premier puis le pays
organisateur mais voilà ça commence à se
mettre en place et d'ailleurs c'est en
1908 à londres que l'américain ne voudra
pas abaisser salué le exactement le roi
d'angleterre ne baisse pas le drapeau
puisque selon lui
nationalisme encore on ne baisse pas le
drapeau de l'oncle sam devant encore
mois devant le roi d'angleterre
voilà mais bon c'est passé comme une
lettre à la poste et encore une fois sur
le marathon
duran duran duran cette olympiade là
vous avez une arrivée épique avec un
italien qui arrive sur les derniers 100
mètres dans un état pas possible a
titubé à tomber et la foule vient
l'aider en fait sous la clameur de la
foule et on l'aide à passer la ligne
d'arrivée
sauf que bâle il s'appelle pietri notre
malheureux pietri n'avait rien demandé à
personne est disqualifié oui mais voilà
logique paris 1924 donc on en fêtera le
centenaire quand nous aurons les jeux
olympiques
on a complètement oublié par 1924 on a
l'impression qu'on a déjà vu les jeux
olympiques que les jeux olympiques
d'hiver
comment ça s'est passé paris 19 100 m 4
le premier village olympique je crois
c'est le premier village olympique
bon en fait il faut un petit peu rendre
à césar ce qui appartient à césar
c'était plus colombes 1924 parce que le
stade olympique et le village olympique
était situé à colombes le fameux stade
de colombes le fameux stade de colombes
bon le comment dire l'urbanisme et de la
disponibilité de la place pour
construire un stade olympique en plein
coeur de paris
hormis l'actuel site du parc des princes
il n'y avait pas 36 solutions donc la
meilleure solution la solution idoine
était d'aller sur colombes est
effectivement est entré dans la charte
olympique
le l'obligation de fournir aux athlètes
un hébergement un accueil avec avec de
la nourriture du monde entier et c'est
la première fois donc où effectivement
les les athlètes du monde entier étaient
réunis en un même lieu
certains ont fait un petit peu leur diva
en louant des sites un petit peu plus
lointains comme les américains ou les
scandinaves qui voulaient leur bain dans
le jardin mais il avait la possibilité à
faible coût de d'être hébergée par la
famille olympique en fait et sachant
qu'ils sont amateurs tous à l'époque
très important il ya d'ailleurs
régulièrement des scandales parce
qu'intel a touché de l'argent c'est
héréditaire mais la lame et tourisme est
encore est encore une valeur importante
oui l'amateurisme c'est le principe même
de
des jeux olympiques c'est à dire que
sportif qui touchent de l'argent dans sa
pratique sportive est considéré comme
professionnel donc n'a pas le droit de
participer aux jeux olympiques
ça a évolué bien sûr aujourd'hui c'est
plus le cas mais effectivement vous avez
des grands champions qui ont été
empêchés de participer à des olympiades
du fait en retouche et des quelques
quelques piécettes de signer là à
l'issue d'une course le grand
bouleversement d'être vraiment de
on va dire donc 1988 vous avez lé
premier tennisman professionnel qui
apparaissent aux jeux olympiques 1992
personne n'a oublié la dream team
américaine
donc là des superstars et qui à l'heure
de basket bien sûr dream team américaine
de basket les michael jordan et
compagnie est hélas ils ont révolutionné
les jeux olympiques puisque là c'était
le système c'était absurde ont donné la
médaille d'or à une équipe de basket qui
était infiniment inférieurs aux vraies
équipes de basket que l'on connaissait
donc tout ça n'avait plus de sens de
toute façon ça n'avait plus de sens et
aujourd'hui voilà ce statut là n'existe
plus bien que aujourd'hui être athlète
de haut niveau dans un autre sport que
le rugby le football ou encore une
poignée d'autres sports est encore
extrêmement difficile
les athlètes aujourd'hui sont à la
chasse aux sponsors il ou alors ils
travaillent en parallèle pour beaucoup
aussi
ils ont des activités l'état recrute
énormément sous forme de contrats images
des sportifs de très haut niveau et donc
du coup ils heures ils leur font
bénéficier d'un salaire mensuel pour
profiter de leur image et mettre en
avant leurs institutions
vous avez la sncf qui fait ça différents
ministères l'armée vous avez l'armée des
champions aujourd'hui avec une bonne
trentaine de sportifs qui vont aller à
tokyo
et voilà la vie d'un sportif de haut
niveau aujourd'hui c'est pas la panacée
non plus mais c'est monsieur au moment
des jeux olympiques c'est tokyo 1964
les champions soviétiques sont tous dans
l'armée les champions américains sont
tous à l'université et nous on hakiki
caron qui paye sa place pour entrer les
piscines pour pouvoir s'entraîner et
elle s'entraîne à la piscine elle
remportera quand même la médaille
d'argent je comble médaille debout pour
s'entraîner à la piscine
elle a droit justin
nager de son côté mais les autres enfin
si vous et moi aurions pu nager à côté
d'elle en ayant payé notre place aussi
là aussi c'est tout bon débat on n'est
pas dans les l'égalité des chances c'est
exactement ça et c'est ce que j'explique
dans mon livre aussi c'est que certains
pays on fait du sport de la pratique
sportive limite une une arme
propagandistes et voilà on va on va
montrer la force de notre pays à travers
les résultats sportifs de nos champions
tout ce qu'on fait dès l'instant quand
les bébés les médailles par pays
l'amérique dit qu'elle va gagner c'est à
londres sont les deux anglais qui gagne
et quand ce sera à berlin les allemands
vont gagner au nombre de médailles
tous l'ont fait à plus ou moins grande
échelle et voilà nous encore même nous
français aujourd'hui on on le fait on
attend dans ces jeux olympiques de tokyo
et voilà des jeux olympiques on a cinq
médailles au total
quoi qu'il arrive ce seront des jeux
sera un échec
ce sera un échec donc oui c'est c'est
pour bomber le torse aussi voilà c'est
ça qui est intéressant aussi d'observer
c'est cette place qu'a pris les jeux
olympiques dans notre société c'est à
dire que ce sont des performances
individuelles ce sont des gens qui qui
vouent leur vie à cette pratique et à
ses exploits et au final on a bon ben on
est une nation derrière ces gens là et
voilà ce phénomène là et qu'il faut
s'accapare exactement les efforts de
laborde ressasser existe en football ça
existe aux jeux olympiques
l'eurovision de la chanson à moindre
échelle
mais sinon moi j'ai pas trente-six
exemple à vous citer ou où on se
rassemble derrière derrière un exploit
on fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après bas à berlin justement en 1936
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec richard va
rignac qui publie histoire des jeux
olympiques chez mareuil édition on est à
berlin en 1936 qui préoccupe tout le
monde avance et je sais de savoir si les
athlètes juifs pourront concourir
normalement comme les autres et pas
seulement les allemands ceux de tous les
pays
oui c'est ce que c'est ce que vers ce
quoi je me penche dans mon ouvrage c'est
de me remettre à la place aussi du cio
face à cette olympiade parce que c'est
une enquête a fait énormément couler de
l'encré et 1931 quand les jeux
olympiques sont désignés pour pour pour
berlin le parti nazi n'est pas encore ce
qu'il a été ensuite ils n'y pensent
pouvoir il n'est pas au pouvoir
la république devait remarque on est
enfin voilà il ya un rapprochement
franco allemand quand même qui se fait
dans l'entre-deux-guerres et voilà il ya
une espèce de grande escroquerie de la
part du pouvoir nazi face au monde
entier et particulièrement face au cio
et donc du coup le président du cio
palais de la courbe qui va rencontrer le
maire de berlin qui va rencontrer hitler
pour être assurés justement pour
rassurer tous ses mouvements qui
commence à monter dans le monde entier
ou et où on parle de boycott déjà où on
s'inquiète du sort réservé aux juifs et
non on le rassure on lui dit non non non
non tout va bien se passer le pourront
ils pourront concourir comme les autres
dans le même temps vous avez toute la
persécution qui commença à monter et le
seuil aubin quelque sorte tombant de
panneaux tombent dans le panneau
il ya eu effectivement des êtres les
juifs non seulement qui ont concouru
mais qui ont remporté des médailles même
une allemand de vous la cité 8 août à
les meilleurs
en escrime sera médaillé olympique elle
est juive et allemandes ça a coûté au
parti nazi 2
de l'accepter oui ils ont pris sur eux
je raconte aussi que justement on a on a
nettoyé berlin aux yeux du monde entier
puisque olympiades c'est le monde qui
vient c'est la presse du monde qui vient
c'est l'image du pays qu'on propose à la
planète entière et donc du coup on a
enlevé tout ce qui est propagande
antijuive
on a nettoyé les murs on a créé des
belles artères n'a oublié d'enlever les
drapeaux nazis bien sûr c'était un petit
peu trop difficile à faire dans votre
livre vous évidemment vous parlez de
jesse owens qui est la star de ces jeux
olympiques mais vous raconter pour une
fois la vérité parce que la plupart du
temps raconte la légende sur jesse owens
c'est la légende du coureur noir que le
führer refuse de saluer et
et en fait il n'en est rien jesse owens
l'a raconté dans son autobiographie
hitler n'a pas du tout refusé de le
saluer il a fait un petit signe amical
depuis les tribunes faut raconter
pourquoi parce qu'on est le cio avait
dit à hitler ça il suffit d'aller saluer
les venelles et les athlètes parce que
c'étaient tous des athlètes allemands
qui gagnait et donc au lieu dit vous ne
savez plus personne
jeudi c'est tout le monde aime ça voila
voila salué des athlètes de couleur
c'était peut-être un petit peu trop dur
oui c'est pas puisque d'après ce que dit
jesse owens il lui a fait ce film très
amicale est ce que des raconte aussi
jesse owens dans son autobiographie que
vous racontez également sexy au bac qui
a refusé de saluer c'est franklin
roosevelt et de gaulle elle vit
exactement et lorsqu'ils résident est de
retour avec ses belles médailles d'or
autour du cou aux états unis il se
confronte à la ségrégation immédiate à
la savate les élections et donc
roosevelt ne veut pas saluer un sportif
noir même médaillée olympique pour pas
déplaire aux électeurs du sud est et au
web ce qui est quand même sans doute le
plus triste dans son autobiographie dit
que peut-être que la seule fois de sa
vie où il a été libre c'était pendant
les jeux olympiques de gala avait quand
même un paradoxe
et oui il était un sportif qui évolué en
finale des jeux olympiques face à un
stade plein bondé certes d'allemand mais
cent mille personnes déchaînées et
remporté ces titres au nez à la barbe
d'autres champions enfin voilà l'exploit
aussi je crois qu'elle a il était plus
que jamais dans son élément
et moi je cite aussi l'exemple de
l'allemand lutz longue qui est un de ses
concurrents sur le saut en longueur et
c'est créer une amitié durée cjo
elle est assez connue mais moi j'ai
réussi à retrouver quelques éléments
notamment une lettre qu'elle avait
envoyé lui tsonga à jesse owens où il
lui demandait
lorsque la guerre sera finie parce qu'il
sentait qu'elle est renvoyée au front et
qu'il allait qu'il allait mourir devenir
ensuite après la guerre en allemagne
pour raconter à son fils 20 l'amitié qui
peut exister entre hommes entre un homme
de couleur de couleur noire issue d'une
famille avec je ne sais plus combien je
crois dix frères et soeurs et de l'autre
côté un lieu de l'ong
issu d'une famille allemande un peu
bourgeoise et communes et bien malgré
tout ça une amitié se crée entre
sportifs en
athlète alors après vous raconter le les
jeux olympiques suivants il veut douze
ans plus tard puisqu'il ya la seconde
guerre mondiale entre les deux les jo de
londres en 48 dans un pays encore
rationnés c'est vraiment vous parler des
j'habite de l'austérité mais il faut
voir il n'y a même pas de village
olympique
alors là c'est comme dirait l'autre à la
bonne franquette c'est à dire que on met
des athlètes dans des dans des dortoirs
d'école les américains viennent avec un
bateau des athlètes dorment sur un
bateau
les argentins viennent avec de la viande
les italiens avec des pattes
enfin voilà les français avec du vin
avec du bon vin oui les pertes de
anglaise par la seconde guerre mondiale
et notamment à londres
la ville est ravagée évidemment les
allées les londoniens ont payé un lourd
tribut de la deuxième guerre mondiale
mais malgré tout dans l'histoire des
jeux olympiques ces jeux de londres
apparaissent comme une réelle réussite
ils ce sont des jeux sans sans fard sans
paillettes
ce sont des vrais jeux olympiques ou où
c'est vraiment la place à l'athlète etc
ce sont des jeux spontanée en fait voilà
et c'est drôle parce que ceux de sedan
ce la presse et helsinki en 1952 et là
c'est l'arrivée de l'urss qui ne
participait plus aux jeux olympiques
depuis que la russie était devenu
communiste et l'arrivée aussi avec du
bloc de l'est qui qui est ils ont tous
leur propre village
en fait il doit vraiment le rideau de
fer et même à l'intérieur du des jeux
olympiques exactement là il ya deux
villages le village de l'est et le
village de l'ouest le village de l'ouest
qui ouvre ses portes aux qui est à deux
pas du stade olympique où la presse s'y
balade où tous les sportifs occidentaux
se sont rassemblés et moi en fait je me
suis aussi beaucoup penchés sur la
presse de l'époque et j'ai retrouvé des
articles notamment d'un reporter qui qui
titre on m'a ouvert les portes du
village de l'est et là dans le ton dans
tout le vocabulaire dans
dans la description dans la manière de
raconter tout ça on voit là il crée une
ambiance sombre à l'est vu de l'ouest
war et alors là c'est le retour
également de l'allemagne qui n'avait pas
eu le droit de participer aux jeux
olympiques de 48 comme elle n'avait pas
eu le droit de participer aux olympiques
d'anvers en 2009 120 qui se faisait
suite à la première guerre mondiale
mais c'est seulement 56 à melbourne
qu'on va réunifier l'allemagne je
l'ignorais en fait on demande à la rfa
et la rda de ne faire qu'une allemagne
pour disputer les jeux et c'est ce
qu'ils font exactement quand on pense
qu'à ce moment là ils sont à couteaux
tirés
on s'espionne des deux côtés de la
frontière et on va aller courir ensemble
jeux olympiques très belles images c'est
une belle image le cio contribue
justement ce rassemblement aussi ou en
cédant sur les comités nationaux
olympiques de l'est et de l'ouest de
l'allemagne de l'est de l'allemagne de
l'ouest ou en fait ils vont établir une
série de règles donc le chef de la
délégation sera le représentant du pays
qui aura le plus de participants la
communication quoi qu'il arrive se fera
à l'ouest enfin voilà il ya toute une
série de règles effectivement le seuil
on réussit parfois à faire tomber des
barrières que la diplomatie
internationale n'arrive pas à une flore
et ouais ou au contraire a fait tout
pour élever mais le bond de 56 est
intéressant parce que c'est juste après
la crise de suez qui a vu les anglais et
les français
partir à l'assaut du canal de suez que
vedette nationaliser nasser c'est aussi
après l'intervention soviétique à
budapest et vous raconter le match de
water polo urss hongrie on est juste
après l'intervention à budapest et ça
devient une piscine rouge sang c'est ça
c'est ce qui se bat on le voit
d'ailleurs sur les photos là il né
les b qu ils elles feront maculé de sang
on est trois semaines après l'arrivée
des chars russes est effectivement
nostra 10 arrive en quarts de finale ce
match là dans une piscine olympique
comble à la cause des hongrois est
effectivement très très vite la violence
intervient j'ai réussi à retrouver des
images et du coup c'est assez incroyable
à voir effectivement au début on cache
ses coûts comme ce formateur paulo c'est
pas un sport non plus enfin voilà c'est
pas de la danse vont faire mal il ya de
réels contacts en water-polo mais arrive
un moment les les coûts ne se cache plus
et on se frappe littéralement dans la
piscine à tel point que à quelques
secondes de la fin alors que la hongrie
gagnent 3 0 le public australien était à
deux doigts de lyncher les russes
effectivement on doit évacuer tout le
monde et la hongrie fini par gagner par
exemple a été la médaille d'or et au
retour il manque une grande partie de la
délégation de l'équipe de water-polo
hongroise qui est passé qui est passé à
l'ouest et tokyo 64 ça c'est les les
premiers géo en asie melbourne c'était
en océanie là on a les premiers jo en
asie il faut savoir qui devait avoir
lieu en 1940 ils en ont été empêchés par
la seconde guerre mondiale et à lancer
des jeux très important pour les
japonais puisque l'occupation américaine
a cessé en 52 donc c'est un pays libre
qui prospère et très moderne etc les
premiers jeux en mono vision exactement
exactement les japonais on voit en voir
satellite justement pour pour diffuser à
l'époque on touche 800 millions de
téléspectateurs mais effectivement les
moyens sont sont voués sont enfin son
incommensurable
on commande ils utilisent ils utilisent
les jeux olympiques comme comme une
relance économique ils configurent l'
architecture de la ville ils
construisent un tgv des lignes de métro
ils reconstruisent des routes
voilà il se sert vraiment c'est là en
fait on commence à toucher notion qui
est actuel ou
on parle d'héritage l'héritage olympique
c'est à dire on reçoit des jeux
olympiques mais on en fait quelque chose
aussi pour l'après jo ce que certains
ont réussi ce que certains ont
réellement raté et encore récemment et
c'est là où il ya de beaucoup de pays
africains pour la première fois on est
au lendemain des indépendances et et
donc les africains arrivent aux jeux
olympiques
exactement exactement et donc du coup ce
sont des jeux bain les premiers en asie
des pays africains qui arrive donc voilà
là on touche en fait du doigt ce que
vous voulez coubertin enfin c'est à dire
bah ce cet universalisme des jeux
olympiques des jeux olympiques en fait
c'est pour lui c'était les sportifs du
monde entier qui se réunissent pendant
15 jours sous un même objectif faire du
sport mexico 68 alors on est en 68 les
contestations et général et ça commence
mal puisque juste avant l'ouverture de
des jeux olympiques elle massacre des
étudiants sur la place des trois
cultures a à mexico entre 300 et 500
morts aujourd'hui ce serait pas possible
on empêcherait peut-être les les jeux
olympiques de se tenir
et puis surtout jamais personne n'aurait
été assez fou pour tirer sur des
manifestations quinze jours avant
d'ouvrir la piste dans son propre pays
à l'époque on peut à l'époque on peut et
à l'époque les bains ils seront
peut-être pas compte que la presse du
monde est là et assistent je retrouve
lartigue d'un art n'avance porte d'un
journaliste de l'équipe qui décrit
justement toutes ces scènes là et
effectivement c'est violent la
répression est immédiate et voilà il
faut il faut faire taire il ya eu aussi
ces étudiants réunis la nuit d'avant ont
un peu accrochés dans toutes les villes
des pancartes anti giot et ça je pense
que ça a été un élément qui a fait 10
février le gouvernement pour justement
l'époque que toute l'amérique latine ce
sont des dictatures évidemment coiffée
par les américains mais il ya quasiment
aucune démocratie
alors si je vous ai juste jeux
olympiques vont être marqués encore une
fois par une autre contestation c'est
celle des des athlètes nord américain
tommie smith et john carlos
on se souvient de cette image
extraordinaire poing levé
tête baissée en chaussettes pendant le
l'hymne américain
une image qui a fait le tour du monde
qui leur a coûté très cher vous raconter
que cet ami suisse qui c'est qui qui
ensuite a été obligé de venir laveur de
voiture ils avaient des contrats
faramineux qui se sont tous arrêtés
immédiatement
il le savait d'ailleurs il a dit m elle
avait des voitures lorsqu'on a oublié en
revanche c'est que quelques jours après
où le lendemain même les trois premiers
du 400 m sont montés sur le podium avec
des béret noir black panther d'autant
plus symbolique d'autant plus en plus
déjà juste pour revenir sur l'image de
ce podium las du 200 m moi j'ai une
pensée pour l'australien ouais qui
arrivait avec l'argent qui lui a donné
aux deux américains la paire de gants
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont un qui porte le
gant gauche et de l'autre le gant droit
et lui avait encore une carrière à
accomplir derrière et n'a jamais pu lui
déjà s'était illustré dans son pays pour
défendre les aborigènes exactement et
les aborigènes ont été considérés comme
de la faune et de la flore en australie
jusqu'en 1967 donc exactement
sauf que lui du coup n'a jamais pu re
participer au giro alors qu'il avait
largement le niveau il était il était en
tête et c'était le meilleur dans sa
discipline
et lorsqu'il est mort dans les
ce qui est décédé dans les années 80-90
cependant les deux américains se sont
rendus en australie pour son enterrement
est en fait il sait créer quelque chose
entre eux aussi et c'est ça à moi que
j'aime aussi dans les jeux olympiques
c'est des histoires donc on est dans la
géopolitique
on est dans l'organisation on est dans
l'histoire des jo mais aussi on est
aussi dans l'histoire entre hommes entre
femmes entre sportifs et c'est ça aussi
qui est beau dans les choses on a pu
tout ce qu'on raconte et john carlos et
tommie smith c'est la haine les les
hurlements dans ce moment là que nous on
voit toujours de façon très recueillie
solennel et silencieuse en fait il se
fera à agonir d'injures
il a sept morts or c'est violent et
devant table alors que qu'au fond ils
n'ont rien fait ils n'ont rien fait ils
ont juste profité d'une d'une lucarne
grande lucarne médiatique pour pour
faire valoir des opinions politiques
et ça le cio ne veut pas en entendre
parler et les exclus dès le lendemain
outré voilà plus d'une fois on en a eu
dans l'histoire même très récemment on
en reviendra peut-être toute heure on
sait très bien que si des athlètes juifs
à berlin en 1936 avaient manifesté
contre contre les persécutions juive au
en allemagne où on aurait trouvé ça
formidable
clary manifestent contre les
persécutions dont les noirs sont
victimes nous états unis et tout le
monde les a crus dida tu vois oui on est
en 1968 donc du coup voilà ce sont des
jo de cette société de ce moment là et
voilà cette société de ce moment là
n'est pas celle d'aujourd'hui est
effectivement voilà ils ont ils ont
arrêté leur carrière après après ce
geste là obama
combien de temps après combien de temps
après ils ont fini entraîneurs tous les
deux voilà mais ils ont pu revenir sur
sur les pistes d'athlétisme mais
effectivement il le savait en le faisant
ce geste il le savait mais il le savait
après y'a munich 72 alors là c'est là
c'est plus la contestation là c'est le
massacre le massacre des athlètes
israéliens par des terroristes
palestiniens en allemagne en plus
la police allemande et youri tu es
plutôt en dessous de tout il faut
remettre aussi des choses à leur place
l'allemagne est traumatisé par les jo de
1936 on évoqué tout à l'heure ils
veulent se rattraper aux yeux du monde
donc effectivement avoir des des
policiers armés dans le village
olympique
voilà il faudrait pas il voulait pas
faire ça de ces blocos enfin voilà et
donc du coup effectivement il ya eu il
ya eu quelques légèretés de la part de
la police et des enquêtes qui ont été
faites et des normes reportage de
nombreux reportages qui ont apporté des
informations effectivement montrant que
un policier a notamment dit on escalade
pas des vrais ce en claquettes
voilà donc israéliens qui sont morts
tout à fait ce jour là ça a été un mois
je m'en souviens encore j'étais enfant
mais vous savez été terrible 2 on
n'imaginait pas que le on savait que les
jeux olympiques étaient le théâtre aussi
de la politique on n'imaginait pas que
ça puisse devenir le lieu d'un massacre
ouais bah là on touche
voilà c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure on touche au monde du sport on
touche à une espèce de choses profondes
qu'on a effectivement là la politique
fait son entrée de plein fouet dans le
monde olympique la guerre plutôt la
guerre oui bien sûr la violence inouïe
et du coup la question après après après
ce drame
est ce que les jeux doivent continuer
voilà est ce qu'on laisse la place au
sport et donc le lendemain il ya eu il
ya une cérémonie au stade au stade
olympique de munich avec 88 personnes et
le président du cio dit que les jeux
continuent
voilà c'était évidemment plus les mêmes
jeux olympiques
je vous souhaite la paix mais on se
demande toujours qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire dans ses meubles on l'ad'ailleurs
s'élevait pas été reproché au président
du cio d'avoir ça a été un soulagement
pour tout le monde que les jeux
reprennent
je pense personnellement j'étais tanné
mais effectivement voilà vous aviez des
champions qui
d es tout à l'heure qui s'entraîne aussi
le public le public est derrière ces
écrans derrière la radio voilà il faut
pas laisser non plus gagner oui c'était
plutôt ça c'est qu'on ne peut pas
laisser gagner les terroriser
terroristes on peut pas laisser gagner
la violence ni l'horreur donc voilà
après ça fait quelques polémiques encore
dans l'histoire puisque les femmes et
les familles de ses victimes de cet
attentat
on souhaitait qu'on rende un hommage
durant la cérémonie d'ouverture des jeux
olympiques sous forme de minute de
silence et ça jamais été ça jamais été
accordée par le cio quels sont les quand
vous voulez regarder puisque vous
n'étiez pas né pour la plupart
rétrospectivement vous les avez tous
étudié minutieusement les uns après les
autres parce que là on s'arrête là parce
que l'émission se termine mais il y en a
encore ce que ça va jusqu'à même jusqu'à
paris 2024 donc vous donner une version
idyllique on peut rêver que ce soient
les plus beaux jeux olympiques de
l'histoire mais les auquel auriez vous
aimé assister
alors moi ce que je mets sur la première
place du podium ce sont des jeux de
barcelone 1992
on est a lâché après la chute du mur de
berlin
il ya une esprit de légèreté barcelone
est devenu le barcelone d'aujourd'hui
grâce aux jeux olympiques il se passe
quelque chose à barcelone tous les soirs
partout dans la ville
il y a le sport mais il ya la vie dans
la ville aussi est ce que génèrent les
jeux olympiques derrière je pense qu'ils
n'ont jamais été aussi ça n'a jamais été
aussi fort qu'à barcelone et les
exploits sportifs aussi bien sûr oui
bien sûr d'autres d'autres à écouter en
y revenant je pense que ceux de 84 bien
qu'ils aient eu le boycott de la russie
sur les jeux de los angeles
là on était un show à l'américaine un
jeu mais déjà en 1932 en 1991 sur mon
voisin que los angeles effet son sac sur
bien sûr et pourtant c'est la grande
dépression exactement exactement et
vaille que vaille on y va on organise
les jeux ça coûte mais au moins on fait
plaisir aussi au peuple
voilà c'est ça aussi que place au jeu
aujourd'hui on parle on parle beaucoup
de dopage sur les déjà dit mais on parle
aussi beaucoup d'endettement et que les
jeux olympiques sont 6e sont synonymes
quasiment deux gouffres financiers dont
la ville ne se remettra jamais alors
aussi que ça a été vrai pour certaines
villes pas du tout pour d'autres mais
qu'en est il exactement c'est quand même
un risque alors c'est un risque
en fait tout vient de surtout des jeux
de 1976 à montréal où le maire qui
s'appelait jean drapeau le maire de la
ville est tombé dans le panneau de
certaines escroquerie enfin voila il n'a
pas été extrêmement minutieuses sur le
suivi et des différents coûts et
derrière ça a coûté 30 ans de dettes à
la ville et aux habitants de la ville à
partir de ce moment là
on s'est posé beaucoup de questions sur
est ce que ça vaut vraiment le coup
donc 1985 moscou on donne d'énormes
moyens à l'événement 1984 il n'ya que
los angeles qui se présente parce que ça
coûte cher
hélas les américains décident
subventionnés sur fonds privés
cet événement là et là aujourd'hui
effectivement vous avez eu certes un
certain gouffre financier on va citer
athènes on va citer rio où on a ce qu'on
appelle les éléphants blancs les
éléphants blancs ce sont ces sites
olympiques construit magnifique pour
accueillir ben sûr qu'un jour une
compétition et qui aujourd'hui sont
laissés à l'abandon
voilà rien on n'avait pas prévu
enfin à part la coupe du monde de
football ensuite mais on n'a pas pensé à
cet héritage pour revenir par exemple
sur 2024 le créneau là était vraiment on
utilise 95% de sites qui existent déjà
donc on réduit au maximum la
construction de deux nouveaux et
l'échiné se sont pas forcément des
stades c'est le grand palais pour les
compétitions des scream c'est se sont
déjà taillé stade éphémère aussi comme
la place de la concorde où il y aura
tout ce qui est bmx ou fin enfin
breakdance
voilà donc du coup là on aura une
tribune pour 15 jours après ce qui coûte
c'est tout ce qui est autour comment se
déplacent comme on loge les gens enfin
voilà la question est là donc du coup
c'est c'est là où en fait les jeux
olympiques peuvent devenir limite un
projet de société aussi pour un pour un
pays ça booste des dossiers sa bouche
des projets qui sont peut-être les 118
eu depuis fort longtemps et grâce à
l'olympisme au fait d'accueillir les
jeux olympiques on dynamise par exemple
le grand paris des transports pour les
jo de 2024
c'est un dossier qui traîne depuis très
longtemps et là peut-être que ils vont
le faire aboutir
tania question echard part de gnac
le cio cette gouvernance mondiale on la
voit parfois comme
comme un colonisateur qui nous imposent
telle boisson tell tale telle et telle
chose vous le voyez comment vous le cio
c'est un petit peu le gardien du temple
c'est son bébé les jeux olympiques c'est
son bébé ou c'est son capital à son
capital c'est son bébé il entretient et
le fait grandir il le fait fluctuer et
effectivement le cio voilà comme je le
disais tout à l'heure au tout début de
l'histoire olympique le cio tour de
pierre de coubertin c'était une certaine
élite et du coup ça a été perpétuée donc
se poser la question comment entre-t-on
au cio
comment on choisit une ville haute enfin
voilà il ya comment subventionne comment
le cio génère des des profits autour de
cet événement là donc effectivement il
ya un côté assez flou autour de tout ça
moi j'ai pas voulu rentrer là dedans non
plus dans le livre puisque moi
l'objectif c'était aussi de raconter des
histoires pour faire la grande histoire
et effectivement il ya encore d'autres
chapitre à écrire autour de autour de
l'olympisme histoire des jeux olympiques
c'est cesser paru chez mareuil édition
merci d'avoir passé toute cette émission
avec nous merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
ce sera la rentrée puisque maintenant
les vacances commencent on se retrouve
évidemment pour une quatrième saison de
interdit d'interdire
autour du à la fin du mois d'août allez
[Musique]
oui